we are with the Mike cutter cough skiers
on the board of a grand chest or someone
who has the vision along with others of
course but one of the primary drivers of
this whole event Michael we are here in
Abidjan it was in its planning stages
you want to take a look at this kind of
event and then all of a sudden it's here
round one is done you got a second day
what are your thoughts as you've seen
this event unfold
well actually I feel like we're
expedition of exploring Africa and these
Jordan II we actually succeeded to bring
chess to western Africa and it's very
exciting when you look outside and kids
are playing people just putting chess
sets and playing bleats and always
besides side tournaments you feel that
you accomplished a lot now it's
something that hadn't happened before
very surprised you look at Abu John
place is gorgeous I mean beautiful city
we're right on the lagoon we get the
fantastic views it's it like it should
have been here many years ago it's so
natural to be here playing chess it is
very natural and many people think that
Africa is a desert but in reality it's
very green as you rightly said it's
gorgeous and beautiful here and people
are very nice cordial and happy to see
us and happy to see chess players and
shares development here in Africa
certainly it's one of the best priority
right now that should be it for the
chess world absolutely all those therio
types certainly need to die hard and you
come here you see there's a wonderful
place that it actually is tell me you
see Magnus here as well that's a
historic moment see the sitting world
champion playing chess and doing well
what does that mean for for the tour
not just for Africa but also for the
tour for the tour is exceptional because
a world champion the reigning world
champion who is number one by far by
reading competing again for the world of
actually not only World Championship
title but for ground chess to title and
coming here to Abby John it's a historic
event by itself like we mentioned but
it's even more important that reigning
world champion first time ever came to
Africa and compete against his
competitors elite players he's not
playing just Simon not exhibition Simon
not just visiting Africa he is competing
here and everybody can see him at his
best
yeah and when you hear it it's kind of
silly that it hasn't happened before to
be sure and good that Magnus made his
stamp and said this is ridiculous let's
get it done so Magnus has got we've got
this event here in Africa but you also
never the Grantchester has never been to
Asia that's going to happen as well this
year as we see the tour has expanded now
to include Calcutta India also a new
stop in Bucharest Romania in addition to
Paris in addition to st. Louis and of
course the finals in London the vision
for the tour seems to be coming into
place as it expands more places more
prized and more players as well that's
right I just want to add one more
classical event in Zagreb also new venue
yes so therefore we expanded on all four
continents on one end and another and we
increase our presence in Europe and now
we going to Eastern Europe like
Bucharest and Zagreb two capitals and
what is important in Zagreb it's the
first ever tournament since Yugoslavia
collapse and divided two different
nations so many studying first that it's
happening this year really surprising
and it's good
tor is making this stamp are you gonna
go to South America I'm sure your
Argentinian fans are thinking that's a
good place to go to or Brazil Brazil
certainly some great capitals there as
well guys have your eyes on that one we
do we have but it would take some time
okay that's a political answer to be
sure but thank you so much for
everything that you're doing for chess
keep up the great work we will thank you
back to you